for seven hours
six-year-old susie was trapped under
piles of rubble
her home was hit by an israeli airstrike
in gaza
her mother and four siblings died
in hospital she reunites with her father
they hold hands facing a new life
without
their family
i was filled with all the anger of the
universe but when i heard that one of my
daughters was alive
i said thank god because this girl might
capture some
even a little of my other daughter's
smile
there's not much room for innocence in
gaza playtime with their new eid toys is
cut
short for the sisters when the sounds of
fighting come
too close for comfort
their father ahmad mansi made youtube
videos that were widely shared on social
media
to distract his kids from the violence
but days after this recording
he died in an airstrike
this boy lost his home he holds back
tears
trying to recover some of his belongings
amid the wreckage a moment of joy for
these children who managed to save their
pet fish
but experts fear these fleeting moments
of happiness may soon be replaced
by long-term trauma my older girl
she's seven years old she looked at me
and said does god really feel what we
are feeling now
and and of course i answered her but
i started thinking what is the mental
state and the
emotional state that she is going
through at this point
to be asking such a such an existential
question
the depths of loss can be overwhelming
especially
for children i don't even know what to
do
i get scared but not really that much i
get
i do anything for my people but i don't
know what to do i'm just 10.
as bombs strike nearby this girl prays
her repeated recitations an attempt to
drown out the sound of explosions
doctors say susie will recover from her
physical injuries
but it's the invisible emotional scars
that may require
long-term attention katya lopez
al jazeera